Saluuut c'est les Daft Punk
C'est extrêmement faux hein
En vrai c'est Justice
C'est toujours faux
*rires*
Aujourd'hui je suis avec Yann en chair et en os
Avec un petit synthé
♪    ♪
Pour faire de la MUSIQUE
On va créer
une musique
Avec fous :D
Avec... avec FOUS !
Yann : On va faire Führer (fureur) !
♪
Voilà.
C'est parti début de la leçon
La mélodie principale c'est parti
D'une petite idée
Attends c'est trop marrant je dis exactement ce que Stromae dit :')
ET PEUT ÊTRE QUE JE VAIS VENDRE AUTANT DE DISQUES QUE LUI HEIN
Donc on part sur un saxo
Yann : sur un saxo alto*
On est parti sur ceci
Voilà.
Yann : ah c'est joli
♪ La mélodie ♪
Yann : j'aime beaucoup :)
Et c'est bien c'est sympa
Yann : Bah c'est nous en même temps donc j'aime beaucoup
Lucas : C'est nous...
ça nous représente
J'sais que Mika il est plus...
♪
Lucas : Voilà nous on est plus...
Yann : Ouais complètement...
Ici quoi !
C'est génial puisque les gens avant de lancer la vidéo ils ont vu... ils ont vu les vidéos de Waxx, de PV Nova
Et là ils arrivent là ils font mais qu'est-ce qu'on branle avec ces 2 boloss ?
*clap* MAIS C'EST ÇA QU'ON AIME !
Yann : On a opté pour un tempo à  *♪* 100 bpm
Une mesure classique en binaire du 4 4
Tout simplement.
*ok*
♪ La mélodie ♪
Yann : On va tout simplement recaler
Mais tu insinues que j'ai pas fait ça dans les temps
Yann : Nan parce que...
Lucas : C'est ce que t'es en train de me dire !
Et si on avait été les Daft Punk on aurait duré un jour, on s'embrouille, au revoir
J'me casse je vais former un autre groupe qui s'appelle Justice !
*Musique de Justice*
Yann : Et là normalement c'est tout droit
♪ La mélodie ♪
C'EST FAN-TAS-TIQUE
Le son est terminé ! *rires*
n'hésitez pas à vous abonnez !
La boîte à rythme est-ce que c'est pas un petit peu ton rayon ?
Yann : Hum effectivement je vais pas te cacher que bon j'ai fait beaucoup de batterie étant jeune... plus maintenant mais il me reste quelques bases
Alors quel son nous as-tu trouvé pour faire cette euuuh... cette boîte à rythme
Yann : Pour l'instant aucun donc...
PARFAIT !
Yann : Est-ce qu'on part sur un truc électro ou est-ce qu'on essaye de se rapprocher plus d'une vraie batterie
Yann : Vous préférez la batterie électro ou la batterie acoustique et tu mets ça sur Twitter tout de suite et on verra...
ON FAIT ÇA !
♪ Bruits de percussions ♪
OOOHHHH
MERCI POUR VOTRE AIDE !
MERCI A TOUS !
Merci à tous pour votre aide ça fait vraiment super plaisir
Quelqu'un préfère la batterie externe
Apparemment
Voilà je trouve ça hyper drôle même si c'est pas ton cas
En attendant que ça se départage Yann j'aimerais que tu nous fasses une blague s'il te plaît
Yann : Bah très bien
Yann : Euuh ce sont 2 prostituées et elles se disputent...
*ah ...*
♪ Pam Pam tcshhhh ! (le bruit des blagues) ♪
Yann : Tu l'as ou pas ?
oui ...
Yann : Vous l'avez aussi ? :D
*oui !*
*symbale*
ça c'est départagé on est maintenant à 824 votes et 53% pour la batterie acoustique
C'est parti Yannou c'est ton domaine fait nous VIBRER
♪ La mélodie ♪  . . . .
Mais attends en vrai on dirait totalement le début de Maître Gims mec
Attends mais on dirait totalement... le début de euuh... de la dernière... j'crois la dernière chanson de Maître Gims
Regarde mec
♪ *Début de "Ma Bauté" de Maitre Gims* ♪
HA HAHA HA HAHA
ÇA RESSEMBLE ÉNORMÉMENT :')
Maître Gims ne strike pas cette vidéo !
Yann : Mais moi ce qui me fait surtout mal c'est... c'est d'avoir fait du Maître Gims quoi :(
Yann : Encore c'était PewDiePie qui avait fait j'aurais compris mais bon
*beaucoup de rires*
♪ Encore la Mélodie ♪
Tu m'as chauffé en 2 notes je m'en vais je vais me faire un thé
Yann tu dis quoi des gens qui boivent du thé déjà ?
Yann : Euuh bah qu'ils ont une orientation sexuelle un peu différente des hétéros mais c'est tout ! (stigmatisant l'homosexualité ptn)
Yann : Donc alors on est parti  sur 2 mesures et ensuite la boîte à rythme rentre à la troisième mesure ce qui nous donne à peu près ceci
♪ Percussions ♪
Simple, efficace
Pouce en l'air !
Yann : Peux-tu nous faire écouter... le saxo ?!
En plus de la boîte à rythme
Yann : Bien évidemment
♪ La Mélodie + Percussion ♪
Je suis Clark Kent et j'approuve ce beat plagié sur Maître Gims
*rires*
On est parti avec le métronome bien sûr
♪ La Mélodie + Boite à rythme ♪
*clap* Merci Yann... pour cette petite basse
♪ Tout les éléments de la mélodie en même temps ♪
Qu'est-ce qu'on est en train de faire Yann ? :'D
Yann : Alors voilà ça c'est le mal de tout... musicien
Tu commences à écouter, à réécouter, à réréréréécouter ton truc et tu te dis c'est vraiment de la merde
Si je puis me permettre...
Yann : Vas-y va te faire mettre !
Tu me parles autrement
Est-ce que dès la première écoute y'avait pas déjà cette impression quand même
Yann : J'avoue que le truc en saxo...
*rires*
On en a conclu qu'il y avait un problème avec ce saxo
Qui finalement énèrve absolument tout le monde ça irrite les oreilles
On trouve le son qui va bien avec ce rythme !
♪ Mélodie style "aquatique" ♪
♪ Mélodie à l'orgue ♪
ARRÊTEZ !
ARRÊTEZ d'exorciser des gens avec cette chanson en fond
♪ Mélodie techno ♪
Ce fut très long de rattraper nos erreurs
Nan mais j'suis content parce qu'au moins on a fini, on a fait un truc bien
Yann : On a tout repris de A à F parce qu'on a pas fait grand chose
Yann : Et euuh vraiment :')
Lucas : C'est vrai c'est vrai y'avait pas eu jusqu'au Z
LÀ on a trouvé des bons... des bonnes rythmiques
Es-tu prêt à balancer ça ?
BAH soyez indulgent ça reste un truc un peu pété mais franchement c'est pas mal
Yann : C'est un premier... c'est un premier jet !
Je te laisse l'honneur de lancer le son c'est parti !
3.   4.
♪ "Get Lucky" des Daft Punk ♪
♪♪ GET LUCKY EAR RAPE ♪♪
C'est la fin de notre chanson
Yann : ARNAQUE
Yann : arnaque*
N'hésitez pas à l'aimer si ça vous à plu à passer voir la chaîne de Yann
Petit teasing : on fera une deuxième vidéo de ce genre avec Yann et ses copains musiciens ! Pour faire un son encore mieux que celui-là !
Merci d'avoir regardé ! à bientôt dans une prochaine vidéo ! c'était Daft Punk... Au revoir.
Yann : Urine.
♪ La Mélodie ENCORE ET TOUJOURS !!!! ♪♪♪♪